if hearin nightly were my friend for the
end of the world I could think of so
many things to do
seeking a friend for the end of the
world star Steve Carrell and Keira
Knightley it's a comedy-drama about the
end of the world this giant asteroid is
hurtling towards Earth it's going to end
in a few days pandemonium in the streets
people are fleeing their jobs and the
opening scene Steve Carl's wife
literally just runs away she doesn't
want to have anything else to do with
him and he starts to regret this
past love he had he wants to find her he
runs into Keira Knightley who wants to
find her family and they decide to help
each other do the last few things they
want to do before this asteroid hits
earth lately I've been trying to do this
thing where I don't watch too many
trailers unless they're for Christopher
Nolan movie of course and I wish I had
done that for this movie because the
trailer for this film
spoils almost every joke for the first
30 minutes and most of the funniest ones
from the rest of the movie and it makes
it look more like a straight comedy and
so people are going to be disappointed
by the fact that this is really actually
more of a drama with some really light
sweet moments inter spliced throughout
and I enjoyed this film a lot I thought
it was a really subtle movie you know it
was lightly funny and Steve Carell is
really good at that he has that everyman
charm to him but he's also hilariously
funny sometimes but in this movie his
performance is more akin to say like
Little Miss Sunshine or Dan in real life
he's really good here and so is Keira
Knightley and I really like their
chemistry with one another I thought
that they worked really well together
on-screen and it was clear that they had
a nice rapport with one another and it
really came across in this movie I
really liked the way their characters
interacted some of the best parts of
this movie are some of the more longer
scenes where their characters are just
talking about things in their past or
things they would like to do or things
they regret or things that they're happy
about in particular this one shot they
have by a fireplace in a house at night
they just talk about their past and
everything and they learn about each
other it was a great scene so movie has
a lot of really good scenes in it
throughout but it also has a few
problems too largely there's a pacing
issue here it seems like the movie is
kind of a mishmash of two different
genres the movie also has a bit of a
bleak and at times depressing feel and
that's understandable considering the
subject matter the world's going to end
but it just sort of clashed with the
different styles the movie was giving it
went from very funny to very dramatic to
kind of depressing and then they all
kind of mix together and it's a little
hard to navigate that emotional
throughout this movie it's strange to
figure out how you feel but this movie
has good and likeable characters and
that's really the high point of a film
is when you feel that the characters are
people you want to stay with that you
want to be with them you want you care
about them you want to see where they go
the movie also has a really good scene
which was of course largely spoiled in
the trailer in which they go to this
place called frenzies it's this
restaurant TJ Miller works there and TJ
Miller hilarious you know he's a really
good stand-up comedian I like him a lot
and it was just a really nice
high-energy seen that kind of picked the
film up for a while but really my main
problem with this movie is the fact that
it navigates so many different genres
and feelings that it's hard to really
latch onto it in that sense but at the
same time though if you were faced with
the end of the world I guess a person
would kind of go through those kind of
feelings where you at one second you're
feeling really happy you're trying to
make yourself feel good about something
in the next second you're not feeling
too good anymore so the way that
mishmash kind of applies to the
situation I'm rambling a little bit here
but for the most part I enjoyed seeking
a friend for the end of the world it's
not an absolute must see but I still
enjoyed this movie and I thought the
actors really saved it I'm gonna give
seeking a friend for the end of the
world of B there's always guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes
Oh